for this episode of bigquery spotlight
we're putting the you and bigquery mean
it's time to start asking questions of
your own data for today's episode you'll
learn how to load and analyze your own
data and bigquery and by the end you'll
have the data you need to answer the
age-old question which is better cats or
dogs for the results of that match up
you will have to stick around
[Music]
if you want to analyze data that's not
already available as part of the public
data sets program or hosted publicly by
another bigquery user you will need to
load your own data into bigquery how you
load the data depends on your analytics
needs and your data pipeline if your
data slowly changes or needs to be
loaded in a one-time analysis you may be
fine with loading the data into bigquery
and batch but if you need to ingest and
analyze data close to real time in this
case you may need to stream your data
into bigquery
luckily bigquery has options for loading
data that cover both of these scenarios
and those in between let's show you how
to get started by loading data in batch
so what data do you need in bigquery in
order to officially crown the winner of
the cats vs. dogs battle we're gonna
determine the champion by analyzing
college basketball tournament games in
order to see who wins
when dog mascots and cat mascots go
head-to-head to run this analysis we'll
need two things first we'll need to have
the tournament results data which is
already available in bigquery as part of
the public NCAA basketball public data
set we introduced this public data set
in our episode on how to query in
bigquery which is linked below if you're
interested second we'll need a list that
has teams with dog and cat mascots which
we have available as a local CSV file
it's also linked below if you're
following along to join these two
datasets together for analysis we'll
need to load the mascot CSV file into
bigquery and create a table no time to
waste let's get started let's first
create a home for the mascot table in
bigquery big query organizes data into
containers called data sets these data
sets function like top level folders
that organize and control access to the
underlying tables let's head over to the
web UI if you want to follow along pause
the video click on the link in the
description below to set up your own
bigquery sandbox where you can load and
analyze data without needing a credit
card all right on to UI to create a new
data set select the project name on the
left hand nav and click the Create data
set button we'll give the data set a
name
and then decide on a location in this
case we need to co-locate our dataset
with the NCAA public data set which is
located in the US multi region will need
to reference both tables in one query by
performing to join and this can only be
done with tables residing in the same
geographical location you can always
view the dataset location by clicking on
the details tab in the web UI click
create data set and the new data set
will appear in the left-hand nav now
it's time to create a new table within
the data set by loading the mascots CSV
file highlight the data set and click
create table this dialog allows us to
directly upload files from our local
machine up to 10 megabytes in size and
containing less than 16,000 rows if you
have something larger don't worry you
can just upload it to cloud storage and
then select it from there
since our CSV is pretty small we can
skip that and use the Browse
functionality to select the file from
our local machine give the table a name
and then define the schema the schema is
a list of each column and its data type
we can define the schema manually by
clicking on add field or check the box
to have bigquery auto-detected click
create table and a load job will be
created once the data has finished
loading you can navigate to view the
table details review the schema and
preview the data right in the console
our mascots table is ready to query
we'll paste in a query that uses the
mascot table to analyse cat vs. dog
tournament game matchups in our query
we've started with our table of
tournament games and then use a series
of sequel joins with the mascots table
to look up the animal classification for
the winning and losing teams we then sum
up the number of wins for cats and the
number of wins for dogs in the specific
cat vs. dog matchup games time to run
our query and there we have it with 43
of the wins dog mascots reign supreme in
the realm of college basketball
tournament games the analysis doesn't
have to saw
there you can see how dogs and cats
perform on other metrics or join this
data with other datasets to test new
ideas for example to the types of
mascots different between warmer and
colder climates comment below with your
ideas of exploring the mascots table we
hope you'll look out for our next
episode of bigquery spotlight and
remember stay curious
[Music]
you